if you thought Deadpool being Ernest
Hemmingway was one of the most
off-the-wall theories on the channel
we'll get ready cuz you ain't seen
nothing yet
what if I told you that 2017 s biggest
horror movie is The Lost sequel to 2018
s biggest kids movie yep
penny wise and wrinkle in time are
connected now I can already see you
throwing your brows through the screen
impatient for some kind of explanation
well get ready because in the words of
Oprah deal I will be a warrior Oprah and
an explanation I shall deliver unto you
you can explanation and you'll get an
explanation and you get an explanation
everybody gets an explanation
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that proves that the fastest
way from point A to point B isn't a line
but rather a theory that teleports yes
straight through the plot holes
ladies and gentlemen leave your Botox at
home for this one because a wrinkle in
time looks pretty darn awesome and I'll
be lining up with the other 90s nerdy
kids to relive my dreams of folding
space-time to save the world today
though we're not here to talk about
magical centaurs or the folding science
of the fifth dimension no sir today
we're talking about something else
or should I say someone else someone
else who you may be familiar with
someone else who literally wrote his
books and movies into the same fictional
universe as a wrinkle in time hit the
snooze button for your Android's and
drive right past that hitchhiker because
I'm not talking about any of those
sci-fi hotshots no sir today we're
talking Stephen King didn't know you're
like that's it Matt perhaps a couple
nuts short of a fruitcake I'm not buying
it and I honestly was super skeptical of
this idea at first too but the more I
looked into it and the more research I
did the more it became unquestionably
clear that Stephen King's universe is
built around the wrinkle in time
universe and you can actually trace the
connections between them across no less
than six books and movies so are you
ready to see how it's done by the time
I'm done with you today you're not gonna
know what's rated our horror from what's
rated G sci-fi which come to think of it
will probably be horrendously traumatic
for your children now before we can set
up our little connected universe
conspiracy it's important that we know
what actually happens in a wrinkle in
time if you haven't read the book and
since this is coming up before the movie
this is your chance to avoid major
spoilers if I really have to give those
kinds of things for a story that was
written back in the 1960s and that
practically all of us have read at some
point between the grades of four and
seven anyway this is your spoiler alert
for the books so just time to travel
your way back to this point in the
episode after you read it all right you
back great the story is about Meg and
her brother Charles Wallace more
super-smart kids but Charles Wallace has
bonus mind-reading abilities where he
can see his sisters and mom's thoughts a
little creepy and hopefully he loses
that ability for a sister when she hits
puberty but whatever we're gonna go with
it their father has mysteriously gone
missing and the whole story is about how
they find and rescue him from across
space-time they do this when Charles
Wallace befriends a mysterious old woman
who lives in the woods public service
announcement by the way do not do this
lo and behold creepy old forest lady
gesso happens to be an interplanetary
shapeshifter named mrs. whatsit and no I
didn't forget her name that's just what
she goes by so mrs. whatsit along with
her two interplanetary shapeshifter
friends mrs. hoo and mrs. which whisk
the two kids and Meg's pseudo boyfriend
Calvin through space to find the kid's
father they travel faster than the speed
of light using something called a
tesseract in science Tessa wrecks are
basically a cube inside of a cube that
you can do all kinds of super advanced
math within a wrinkle in time it
basically makes it so you can fold up
space-time and just hop across the fold
to different parts of the universe so
the kids and the old lady Brigade fold
time so they can travel into space after
some planet hopping they land on a dark
planet consumed by a dark force which
the Galactic which is lazily called the
black thing really creative naming
system in this book Meg's dad happens to
be fighting the black thing and it's the
kids job to save him in their journey
they have to confront the black thing
which controls people's minds and makes
everyone a drone Charles Wallace with
his special mind powers is able to
rescue their father but then gets
himself hypnotized by the black thing
and Meg has to save him through the
power of love well in addition to that
being more than enough information to
write your fifth grade book report there
are a few things in there that should
probably be sounding a bit familiar like
Stephen King familiar in fact I'm here
to tell you that the closer you look at
this story the more you're gonna start
to feel like maybe our buddy Stevie did
a little creative borrowing and made a
few pretty key parts of his universe
match a wrinkle in time in ways that are
a little too on-the-nose to be an
accident point number one let's start by
looking at the main antagonist of a
wrinkle in time shall we in the book
it's just referred to as the black thing
at Lee
until it's referred to by another name
it's forever where she looked everywhere
she turned was the rhythm and as it
continued to control the systole and
diastole of her heart the intake and
outlet of her breath the red miasma
began to creep before her eyes again and
she was afraid that she was going to
lose consciousness and if she did that
she would be completely in the power of
it there it is clear as crystal capital
i capital t it and this isn't the only
time they use it in the book either it
is used consistently throughout the
novel now I know what you're thinking
the it in Stephen King's it is a clown
named Pennywise with great balloons and
really bad teeth where it's in a wrinkle
in time doesn't seem to be especially
cloudy it's more telepathic pulsating
brainy but in reality the way we see
both of these guys in the movies aren't
really what they look like in both cases
it represents pure evil energy or
darkness the way we see them in the
movie is just the form that they happen
to be taking at the time I mean just
look at penny wise in the new movie he
shaped shifts from a clown to a leper to
a girl who just loves her flute a bit
too much meanwhile it in a wrinkle in
time goes between black smoke to
pulsating brain - a guy with red eyes
that hypnotizes Charles Wallace so we
know that both of these villains
represent the same thing they can both
change shapes at will and on top of that
they're both from a galaxy far far away
with the wrinkle and timesit coming from
a distant planet and Stephen King's it
coming from his macro verse a dimension
beyond the one that houses earth but the
parallels don't end there point number
two in both stories it possesses the
power of mind control in wrinkle in time
it's really obvious mind control where
literally everyone is plugged into the
same brain and bounces the same
basketballs and eats the same mac and
cheese in Stephen King's it the force of
mind control is more subtle but it's
still definitely there no adults leave
dairy despite the child murder rate
being massively inflated it is also able
to control the mind
Derry's bullied Henry Bowers which leads
us to point number three the methods the
kids use in a wrinkle in time to fight
it are awfully similar to the ritual of
Jude from Stephen King's it's now you
don't really find the ritual of Jude in
the newest movie but if you're
interested I talk about it a lot more
over on the last penny wise theory I did
let me just see this the novel sets it
up is this massive psychic battle of
wills where the kids defeat it by
refusing to be afraid instead they show
confidence humor all very non afraid
emotions and it can't touch them as a
result this looks mighty familiar if
you're gonna end up watching a wrinkle
in time this weekend we're
self-assuredness and refusing to give in
to fear is actually what saves Calvin
and Charles Wallace from the man with
red eyes one of its various forms to
resist him Charles Wallace starts
spouting off nursery rhymes
Calvin recites the Gettysburg Address
which when he actually stopped to think
about is yet another weird parallel
considering Bill Denver oh this
stuttering leader of the losers Club
fine strength to defeat any wise by
reciting his tone twisters and if that's
still not enough for you both versions
of it also have a weakness to love it's
true I mean think back to the end of the
2017 version of it where Bev is stirred
from her catatonic state when Ben kisses
her Stephen King may have had a little
help in that moment from a really
similar moment in a wrinkle in time
where Meg snaps Charles Wallace out of
its spell not by kissing him thankfully
cuz they're brother and sister but by
telling him how deeply she loves him hmm
similar plot points are similar point
number four Charles Wallace in a wrinkle
in time appears to have psychic powers
with the exact same abilities that
Stephen King's shine ability just like
Danny Torrance in The Shining and as I
said in my last in theory the losers
Club early on in a wrinkle in time Nick
notices that her little brother can
apparently read her mind quote how did
Charles Wallace always know about her
how could he always tell it was his
mother's mind and Meg's that
probed with frightening accuracy end
quote Charles woloson's book can also
sense the evil presence of the man with
red eyes before he ever sees him
correctly predicting that the man is
trying to get at him and into his brain
and it's not just Charles Wallace when
the gang finally does run into the man
who uses no Visine and Meg realizes that
he's talking to them without moving his
mouth or lips at all it is instead
communicating directly into their brains
vote again I've been waiting for you my
dears the man said his voice was kind
and gentle not at all the cold and
frightening voice may had expected it
took her a moment to realize that though
the voice came from the man he had not
opened his mouth or moved his lips at
all that no real words had been spoken
to fall upon her ears that he had
somehow communicated directly into their
brains end quotes now let's take a
moment to revisit dick hallorann from
the shining as he defines what shine
ability is my grandmother and I could
hold conversations entirely without
communication would be one thing it
doesn't stop there if you watched my
film theory on it you know that shining
tends to be linked to childhood trauma
dick hallorann and Danny Torrance and
the shining were both abused by their
families the losers Club are bullied for
being fat Jewish a girl having a stutter
etc and now look at meg and Charles
Wallace from wrinkle in time two kids
who have both had to deal with the
unexplained disappearance of their
father I mean even kid three Kelvin in a
wrinkle in time is established to have a
physically abusive mother all the pieces
are there the kids the telepathic powers
the origin story of course if a wrinkle
in time truly takes place in the same
universe is it that means it's really
taking place in the Stephen King
multiverse which would imply that these
two universes share the same mechanics
enter point number five in both the
wrinkle in time universe and the Stephen
King multiverse characters can travel
outside their own reality while stopping
time when Meg worries that everyone at
home will be looking for her in Charles
Wallace will they go planet hopping this
is what's it assures her that she's
created a little wrinkle in time roll
saying quote we'll have you back about
five minutes before you left so there'll
be time to spare and nobody will ever
know that you were gone at all and quote
this sort of freezing of time while
characters explore other planets and
timelines fits the same rules as the
time portal in Stephen King's novel
11/22/63 in that book a man discovers a
portal that takes him back in time to
1958 and regardless of how long he stays
in the past when he returns to the
present only two minutes have passed I
should also mention that in both a
wrinkle in time and 11/22/63 the
characters are able to affect the events
of their timeline the Murray children
managed to bring their father back even
though they end up going back in time
and the actions performed in the past in
11/22/63 don't change the time that you
arrive but they do change the kind of
world that you arrive back in for good
or bad in this case the main character
Jake Epping discovers this fact when he
comes back to a nuclear holocaust Oh
word and oh yeah if you're wondering
whether 11/22/63 is part of the Stephen
King averse or then rest your pretty
little heads my friends Jake Epping
visits Derry Maine and visits Beverly
Marsh and Richie trouser during his
journey now some of you still might be
skeptical Stephen King's multiverse and
a wrinkle in time both share a lot of
sci-fi elements and themes because well
they're both scifi books duh but what
about the similarities that are a bit
too close to write off as a mere
coincidence things that can only match
up because they're in the same Canon for
instance
point number six in Chapter six of a
wrinkle in time it's revealed that the
three misses w's were all once stars
that have taken human form to act as the
three guides for the children quote to
complete the true mrs. whatsit meg
realized was beyond human understanding
what she saw was only the game mrs.
whatsit was playing I didn't mean to
tell you mrs. whatsit faltered I didn't
mean ever to let you know but oh my
dears I did so loved being a star now
that's a pretty specific and unique
concept stars that can take human shape
and vice versa and yet the Stephen King
averse has got this one too in Chapter
eleven of Dark Tower three the
wastelands we hear the story of upon
Lydia
and Cassiopeia three ancient figures who
become stars won't before time began old
star and old mother had been young and
passionate newlyweds
then one day they had a terrible
argument old mother windows long ago
days have been known by her real name
which was Lydia had caught old star
whose real name was a pond hanging out
with a beautiful young woman named cast
the appeal in the end the gods had to
step in so a pond and Lydia might not in
their anger destroy the universe
Cassiopeia had been banished to a
rocking chair made of stars forever and
ever
- and Lydia are three billion years gone
they've become old star and old mother
the north and south each pining for the
other but both now too proud to beg for
reconciliation and before so humans as
stars and stars as humans if it wasn't
getting weirdly similar before now you
should be really feeling those dots get
connected but perhaps the fundamental
idea that made a wrinkle in time so
unique in literature was the concept of
moving through realities instantaneously
the concept of the tesseract and yet try
as I might to find it it's a word that
Stephen King's multiverse doesn't
mention once so is this where the theory
dies well point number seven the Stephen
King multiverse has peso acting in The
Dark Tower series certain characters are
able to travel through time and space by
using what's called PO - PO - space is
the void between universes and
characters can travel through it to
reach other worlds instantaneously going
to-- - though is very dangerous it's
possible to get stuck between worlds in
the toe - darkness where the monsters
dwell meanwhile mrs. whatsit describes
Tesar acting as making the connection
between two faraway things in a way that
bypasses the distance between them quote
well the fifth dimensions a tesseract
you add that to the other four
dimensions and you can travel through
space without having to go the long way
around a straight line is not the
shortest distance between two points
it's literally finding the wrinkles in
space-time and passing
the empty space they create exactly the
way that toad ash is described so yeah
the terms are different except for the
whole concept of it that we covered for
the first three points of this theory
and yes they may be used for different
purposes but it is clear that both
Stephen King's multiverse and a wrinkle
in time share the same physical wonders
the same kinds of powers and even the
same quantum mechanics so who knows it
certainly seems like wrinkle in time has
all the trappings of being the lost
Stephen King Dark Tower novel even
though it came out like 30 years before
the first one of those it's kind of like
a children's dark tower dark tower for
beginners and if so think of what
craziness this sort of connected
universe would deliver to us this is the
true origin story of it the origin of
penny wise and heck maybe in Chapter two
we'll finally be able to feature Oprah
in the role that she was born to play
match her in the cosmic turtle you know
what a theorist can dream but hey that's
just a theory ah film theory and while
you're floating your way through that
toe - space make sure that you teleport
your way through that subscribe button
so that way you can see what other weird
film franchise crossovers we come up
with and future theories and in case you
missed it the button to the right will
take you to that penny wise theory I
mentioned earlier how the losers Club
all secretly shine now if you'll excuse
me I need to go wrinkle my way to the
nearest lunch location goods I am hungry
see you next week